l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
gouvernement la parole est à monsieur
philippe vitel monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
monsieur le premier ministre après une
longue et âpre campagne électorale le
peuple américain a fait son choix et
nous le respectons donald trump a été
élu le 45e président des états unis
le groupe parlementaire les républicains
lui présente ses sincères félicitations
et ses voeux de succès dans la grande et
difficile mission qui sera la sienne au
service de son pays
la chambre des représentants et le sénat
conserve une majorité républicaine sur
laquelle pourra s'appuyer le nouvel
occupant de la maison blanche
mais cette élection ne sera pas sans
conséquences sur l'équilibré
géopolitique mondiale en effet durant sa
campagne
donald trump a souvent évoqué sa vision
de la future politique étrangère
américaine
il ambitionne en premier lieu un
rapprochement avec la russie de poutine
afin de mieux pouvoir combattre des
chais le terrorisme sa position
concernant le devenir de l'alliance
atlantique devrait elle être précisées
en particulier en ce qui concerne
l'obligation de solidarité qu impose à
ses membres l'article 5
il exhorte en effet ses alliés otaniens
au premier rang desquels les européens à
mieux payer le coût de leur défense et
mieux prendre en compte leur propre
sécurité en désignant d'ailleurs au
passage l'allemagne en tutrice et
guardian du continent pour lui la
reconstruction des états unis doit
primer sur tout y compris sur les
traités de libre échange il prône la
nucléarisation du japon et remet en
question l'accord historique conclu sur
le nucléaire iranien
ils évoquent aussi une éventuelle
renégociation de l'accord de paris sur
le climat monsieur le premier ministre
comment le président de la france et son
gouvernement compte-t-il établir un
dialogue constructif avec la nouvelle
administration de cette grande puissance
qui doit tout temps a été notre ami est
notre allié merci la parole est un
monsieur jean marc ayrault au ministre
des affaires étrangères et du
développement international
là aussi monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous avez rappelé la
décision du peuple américain après une
campagne intense âpre et qui parfois pu
nous surprend mais c'est la démocratie
américaine
elle a désigné donald trump président
des états unis
c'est un choix bien sûr que nous
respectons le président de la république
a adressé ses félicitations et rappelé
la volonté de la france de continuer à
rester un partenaire des états unis nous
sommes le plus vieil allié des états
unis et nous entendons le rester
en tout cas c'est le message que nous
adressons au peuple américain mais en
même temps c'est vrai que un nouveau
président arrive avec des engagements
qu'il a pris et dont certains les et si
tu ne la réification à l'évidence
l'administration américaine va être
profondément transformé 4000 personnes
vont changer de poste c'est le spoil
system c'est le système américain et le
président prendra ses fonctions le 20
janvier prochain jeu ne fait que
rappeler ça ça nous laisse un petit peu
de temps mais nous n'avions pas attendu
l'élection pour contacter les équipes
aussi bien d'hillary clinton que de
donald prône pour essayer de comprendre
qui était la stratégie des candidats
et si les été élu de leurs politiques et
les questions que nous voulons poser et
clarifier concernent notamment celles
que vous avez évoqué l'accord de paris
qui est un accord historique
donald trump a dit qu'il voulait le
dénoncer l'accord avec l'iran sur le
nucléaire qui est un accord de paix qu
accord multilatéral qu'il voulait aussi
le dénoncer ce n'est pas sans
conséquence vous avez aussi rappelés
l'automne
vous avez rappelé les traités de
libre-échange quelles vont être les
conséquences économiques de tout cela il
ya donc à parler avec le président
preuve qu'ils clarifient cassions
obtenir mais la france veut rester elle
même avec ses principes
avec ses valeurs avec sa stratégie son
indépendance et continuer sa mission de
membre permanent de essentielles de
sécurité et un membres merci monsieur
venir